qu'avez-vous fait ce week end les cadets
de rami déjà c'était pas celui qui est
attendu c'est quoi c'est bien sûr snap
chat avec adil rami apparemment pas du
tout attendais pas du tout c'est quoi
cette photo a dû tout nous amuser en
fait je suis comme ça c'est rigolo parce
qu'il a mis un but et j'ai d'autres
dossiers sur moi ah ouais ah bon mais
labernadie dont tu te détends s'il te
plaît et pas du tout en fait j'ai
beaucoup de dossiers restés calmes parce
que depuis la mauvaise vanne de la
semaine dernière beaucoup de boue je
vais vous massacrer
la vengeance est un plat qui se mange
oui c'est ça toulouse est soutenu et
vous avez même groupe que la semaine
dernière je viens de voir si on va si on
résume en régie on peut mettre une photo
de la semaine dernière vous aviez pas un
prennent deux yeux je regarde votre
coiffure votre t-shirt regarde tous je
vous relou comme vous vous relooker mais
snap chatte et c'est bon